لذلك لأول مرة جون كيلي الذي
كان مترددًا جدًا في القيام بذلك بشكل
رسمي أه لكنه هنا يؤكد أه
عدة قصص أه أساءت
إليه كثيرًا أم خاصة تلك التي كان لها
علاقة بموقفه تجاه المحاربين القدامى
أه الجنود الجرحى الذين قتلوا جنود
ترامب  في مقبرة أرلينغتون عام
2017 واقف بين قبور
الجنود الأمريكيين الذين ماتوا في
أفغانستان والعراق ويقول لا
أفهم ما كان لهم ترامب وهو
يصف الأمريكيين الذين ماتوا في الحرب العالمية الأولى
بالخاسرين ولا يرفض زيارة
مقابر العالم  الحرب الأولى أه الجنود أه
ترامب أه لا يريد قدامى المحاربين الجرحى في
عرض عسكري لأنه
لن يقتبس نظرة جيدة له هل سمعت
أيًا من هذه التعليقات أم أو أي شيء
مثلها وهل لديك أي سبب
للشك في معرفة جون كيلي  كما
تفعل جيدًا أولاً ليس لدي أي سبب على
الإطلاق أه للشك فيما قاله جون اه أعتقد أنه
كان يقول بالضبط ما سمعه من
ترامب بعض تلك الأشياء التي أخبرني بها
بعضها حدثت قبل أه
وصلت إلى البيت الأبيض أه ال
سؤال أه يوم المحاربين القدامى
أه الاحتفال بيوم الجيش في فرنسا
أه أنا لم أسمع تلك التعليقات
هناك أعتقد أنني متأكد من أن جون سمعها
عندما كنت خارج الغرفة أه أفعل
شيئًا آخر لا أملكه  أي شك أه
أن ما قاله جون كيلي كان صحيحًا لا شيء
مهما كانت تعليقات كيلي تتوافق أيضًا
مع التقارير الواردة من المحيط الأطلسي
قصة أحدث بقلم جيف جولدبيرج
ملف تعريف للجنرال ميلي أه أن ترامب
لم يتفاعل بشكل جيد لرؤية
كابتن الجيش المصاب بجروح خطيرة أه  الذي كان يغني
"اللهم بارك أمريكا" في حدث في هذه
القصة الأحدث التي كتبها غولدبرغ من
الملف الشخصي لميلي ترامب قال لميلي
لماذا تجلب أشخاصًا مثل هؤلاء إلى هنا،
لا أحد يريد أن يرى هذا الجرحى الذي يجب أن
أقوله على
المستوى الشخصي كشخص يحاول القيام
بالكثير من العمل لمساعدة جنودنا الجرحى أه أه
أنا لا أفهم حتى وجهة
النظر هذه، هؤلاء هم أشجع
الشجعان لدينا وكان هذا الرجل
القائد الأعلى ويريد أن يكون
القائد الأعلى مرة أخرى ولا
يريد أن يرى
الجنود الجرحى يشرحون لي ذلك إذا كنت
تستطيع ذلك، يمكنني أن أخبرك بما
أخبرني به جون كيلي ذات مرة عن الزيارة إلى
والتر ريد التي حدثت أه قبل
وصولي عندما أه معظم الناس  عندما
يرون أعضاء الخدمة الذين أصيبوا بجروح خطيرة
يتأثرون بها،
يذهلون من التفاني في أداء الواجب
الوطني وتفاني أولئك
الذين ضحوا كثيرًا
وتحملوا مثل هذه الجروح الوحشية التي قال ترامب إنها
حاولت الابتعاد عنها و
وفسرها جون كيلي اه أعتقد بشكل
صحيح على أنها جبن من جانب ترامب
خوفًا من أن شيئًا كهذا قد
يحدث له أه يمكن أن يحدث له وهو
فقط لا يريد مواجهته أه
أنا لست طبيبًا نفسيًا أنا لا'  لا تقليص
التشخيص ولكن أعتقد أن تحليل ISM الجبان أه
صحيح